[Music]
what's up guys today
i'm gonna be doing some yard work um
first time doing artwork at the house
actually like like
real yard work uh the yard has been
built by
contractors that we hired and the only
yard work that we've actually done
ourselves i would say it's just watering
our
plants that we have in our garden and
our patio in our backyard so
today i am gonna replant the plants that
are in the backyard because we're trying
to put a fence in between
our plants and our ac unit because our
plants are starting to grow
into the ac unit and to help create a
barrier from the plants and the ac unit
we're going to put that fence in between
and ultimately we don't even know if we
want to have the plants there
by the ac unit just because we've been
reading online and it seems to be pretty
split there's a lot of people that say
it doesn't really matter if you have
things pressed up against your ac
unit and other people are saying that
it's very bad to have things pressed up
against your ac
unit you need a minimum of three feet
three feet we don't we we have a small
yard we can't manage the three feet
in fact it's even close so close to our
house that it
literally doesn't have three feet
already from the two uh sides that is
bordering our house
right now we're just moving forward with
aesthetics uh tiffany with our house and
so
i don't know we might be regretting this
in like five years because i hear
it shortens the lifespan of your ac unit
if you do
have things pressed against the ac unit
and what's supposed to last 20 years
you might be cutting it down to five
years so maybe in five years we'll be
regretting it
and getting a new ac unit i don't know
but if you do know let me know in the
comments down below but before i get to
that
i am super happy about selling some of
the stuff that is in our garage
and this is what our garage looks like
so if you guys remember when we first
moved in we had like isaac's old
bunk bed here we had two more of these
couches that were stacked up all the way
to the ceiling a lot of dressers
and desks and just a lot of stuff that
was at the previous house we've
literally replaced all furniture almost
most of this is from the old house and
just you know color
in terms of aesthetic we wanted to go
something different something more
colorful here
just ran the lead on that and i think
she did a fantastic job so all our dark
gray
and drab and dark wood black
furniture is up for sale and i think
we've done a pretty good job clearing
out i think at this point this has got
to be half of it maybe a little less
than half
remaining we are having the hardest time
selling couches this is actually a
really nice couch
it's got some holes from the cats
clawing at it other than that though
these are fantastic couches nice soft
real leather a faux leather couch very
cheap
one right here we're selling that for
really cheap and this is i think a
pretty good price
can't sell these to save my life but
i've been putting up like hard surfaces
you know tables and stuff they're
selling really really fast so my
assumption is because the kovid maybe
people don't want to you know i guess
you can't clean soft surfaces the same
way you can clean hard surfaces
i don't know that's my assumption that's
the update on the garage once i get to
clear this out i can move my car in here
and stop parking
outdoors and especially with the fires
recently i've been needing to wash my
car like once a week anyways onto the
backyard
this is our uh bush situation next to
the ac unit
and apparently the contractors i don't
think they did a good job
planting these plants and i asked them
if it was okay that the roots were all
exposed like this
they said it was fine but now today this
guy is starting to lean a little funny
it's leaning out towards the walkway
so i'm thinking i think this guy's
fallen out of its like it's just not
planted well enough so i'm gonna dig
all these plants up and um dig a deeper
hole for them
all the roots are exposed and i think
that's not good for the plants i don't
think they're getting the maximum
amount of water maybe you know i don't
know anything about plants i'm not going
to pretend i do let's just go with the
statics again
aesthetic seems to be the reason why we
do anything these days i don't like the
way the roots look how about that
so i'm going to dig them deeper into the
ground
i don't like the way this guy looks so
we're gonna put
these guys in between the plant and the
ac unit um this is kind of cool so tiff
bought a uh gardening kit so we got
some goodies in here that's gonna help
me out shovel gigantic gardening fork i
don't know what this is for another
uh shovel a bent fork garden gloves
spray bottle
make butterflies for like decoration or
something
aesthetics all right my common sense
tells me that i should use
either one of these let me use one of
these too to till up the
land you know what i'm gonna do i didn't
plan this well enough
i just realized if i dig up these plants
i need them to be somewhere in the
meantime so i'm gonna put them in this
planter that we've never
actually used as a planter so it'll be
serving its original purpose
this has always just been a container
for us to put stuff in
[Music]
you know i was stressing so much about
whether or not these roots are going to
absorb water
i did not realize how far the roots go
[Music]
i'm starting to think this is a bad idea
because if i put this in here and if i'm
trying to give it like maybe
say four inches of space on this side
this is what i'm left to work with
i don't think that's gonna allow these
plants to be planted in this
remaining space i don't think that's
gonna work
[Music]
what do i do all right so what i think
i'm going to do is
remove plants all together just not
worry about plants for now
and make sure that this fence has enough
spacing
probably just punch up against the floor
here and give them as much spacing back
here as pos
as much as possible for the ac unit to
breathe you guys are going to be living
somewhere else then
all righty now i am with the wifey
going to home depot now we're going to
wifey looked at it
and uh we concur that uh we are not
gonna put the plants in that area
probably are we gonna put flowers there
maybe i don't know so
we are now here to ask professionals
what kind of planters to put the plants
in because now they're like on life
support right now currently
so we shall see we're trying to buy
plants
we're supposed to go to like a nursery
because
home depot and like corporate stores
they don't like they ship in the plants
so they could easily just die being here
because they're not used to this climate
oh true so i don't think we should be
buying plants here i think
just planters see the yeah the planters
which are okay
okay let's go over there oh yeah these
are cool
ah jenks no he's dead yeah you're cool
oh that's cool take one of those one of
those one of those
oh look at the bamboo ones over there no
that's not a planner
i was actually thinking about putting
that behind the couch i don't think it
fits in my car
oh yeah we need to get an suv one day oh
these are cool though i like them
you know how you were saying that you we
want to get our garden to be
part of your culture in my culture yeah
michael yeah i know that's why i said
i was i was thinking about these nice oh
cool i don't like that but better than
the fence that we have for the ac unit
this would be
super feature yeah but then we could put
things yeah we could put vines on it and
stuff
what do we do with the fence we bought i
don't know sell it all right just got
back to the house
and uh this is what we got from home
depot for these red pots
three of these blue ones potting mix i'm
told
that we are supposed to drill some holes
at the bottom of this thing so it's
gonna go on like that
on top of one of those dishes planter
saucer tiff also picked up some paints
for her
highly anticipated project of stenciling
and painting
our backyard concrete area we took a
photo of the front porch and
a photo of the backyard and tiff even
learned photoshop and applied the
designs
uh onto the pictures to see what it
would look like and through that we
figured out the color schemes that we
wanted to go with so today we picked up
some paint i'm ready to go with that and
uh yeah it's gonna be some good times
more transformations for our backyard
and front yard right now i'm about to go
into these pots and drill a couple holes
i'm told
by the guy at home depot that i need to
do about a pinky
sized hole at the bottom of each um pot
so that i could
properly drain everything so we'll see
what happens and plus the plants are
still out
and exposed so they're just drying out
so they i i need to work fast we
actually spent a lot of time waiting for
the paints at home depot
plants so still on life support here we
go
[Music]
all right so you might be wondering why
did we choose to go with
plastic rather than like clay
is that what you call it ceramic pots i
don't know i don't know why either
actually yeah you know what
yeah i do know why home depot did not
have a very big selection
and just based on aesthetics and what we
thought looked nice
they just happen to be the the plastic
ones
so i don't know i don't know if there's
like a pro and con
to plastic versus ceramic pots but we
got plastic that's what we're working
with so
let's go
[Music]
all right it is the next day uh last
night it got too dark so i couldn't show
you the final results
of finishing up the plants putting them
in planters and
organize them along our backyard but
here is our final result
i'm pretty proud of this because i did
it all by myself
it's between me and tiff tips more the
uh interior decorator slash like she
just knows where to put things to make
it look nice and utilizing the space
and i was like you know what let me
handle the backyard baby and uh this
is my attempt so i spaced it out three
tiles apart
each one and i was like very systematic
there and then i
put one here just because it just felt
like i needed something there i had
another one here
and this one i left it here because this
color does not exactly match the
original house color
uh it's very close but slightly off and
when you see it back like right next to
each other it
just it just bugs me so i wanted to put
a plant here to hide that crease
and then the last thing i did was
putting one more plant over here
it's like storage stuff back there but
just felt like i needed something to
block
the storage stuff tiff and i realized we
weren't a fan of the the fence that
we're putting
by the ac unit it looks really ugly
actually and it
makes it even worse than just seeing the
ac unit i'd rather see the ac unit than
seeing these the fence that's there not
quite sure we're gonna do about that
probably end up selling the fence and i
don't know to be continued
[Music]
you